tackling the NHS backlog is a top
priority for the government and health
leaders but on Monday some patients
won't receive the care they were
expecting
Joan has stage four breast cancer it's
now spread to her bones tests she needs
have been delayed because of reduced
bank holiday NHS Services when things
are taken out of your control and when
you don't have a time scale it's very
frightening it's treatable but it's not
curable
so any delay in any treatment that I get
means that anything could be happening
in my body and I have no idea the number
of people waiting more than two months
to start cancer treatment is three times
higher than when David Cameron took
office 12 years ago and the total
waiting list for all treatments after
referral is at an all-time high at
nearly 7 million people
NHS leaders say major surgeries urgent
and Emergency Services will still be
available staff need to have the
opportunity to pay the respects to the
queen but there's also a few other
practical matters so many NHS staff have
children who will all be off school on
that day we know from past experience
that on public holidays quite a lot of
people tend to cancel or not show up to
their non-emergency appointments
but even missing routine appointments
will make some patients anxious the
government says it's letting NHS trusts
make local decisions because they'll
understand the needs of their area
better than anyone else NHS trust
leaders say they have to balance the
needs of their staff and their patients
many patients sympathize with the NHS
but say the government should have taken
their needs into account when the
Queen's funeral decisions were being
made
oh she's Joshi's Sky News in central
London